NEXT WAVE OF TRUMP ACCOLADES
FRESH FROM PRIMARY VICTORIES
THIS WEEK.
HERE'S MORE.
>> Reporter: FRESH OFF A
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY VICTORY, KARI
LAKE ARRIVES TO A HERO'S WELCOME
AT THE CONSERVATIVE POLITICAL
ACTION CONFERENCE IN DALLAS.
>> WE DID IT.
>> Reporter: IN HER HOME STATE,
HE'S LEADING IN EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY CENTERING HER CAMPAIGN ON
DONALD TRUMP'S LIE ABOUT THE
2020 ELECTION, A POSITION SHE
PLEDGES SHE WILL NOT PIVOT AWAY
FROM.
>> WE OUTVOTED THE FRAUD.
WE DIDN'T LISTEN TO WHAT THE
FAKE NEWS HAD TO SAY.
THE MAGA MOVEMENT ROSE UP AND
VOTED LIKE THEIR LIVES DEPENDED
ON IT.
>> TRUMP ENDORSED
ELECTION-DENYING CANDIDATES WON
UP AND DOWN ARIZONA'S BALLOT
TUESDAY.
BLAKE MASTERS AND SECRETARY OF
STATE CANDIDATE MARK FINCHAM
SAYS HE WANTS TO ELIMINATE ALL
VOTING MACHINES.
>> WE CAN DO THAT.
WE USED TO DO.
>> Reporter: ELECTION EXPERTS
SAY THAT WOULD MEAN MONTHS LONG
COUNTS.
NOT JUST IN ARIZONA.
>> THANK YOU, MICHIGAN.
>> Reporter: BUT IN MICHIGAN
THIS WEEK, REPUBLICAN
GUBERNATORIAL NOMINEE TUTOR
DIXON.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE DONALD TRUMP
LEGITIMATELY WON THE 2020
ELECTION IN MICHIGAN?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: NOW DIXON IS
DODGING THAT QUESTION.
>> THERE WERE SOME THINGS THAT
HAPPENED IN MICHIGAN THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN IN OTHER STATES WHICH ARE
VERY CONCERNING.
>> Reporter: THESE WINS ARE JUST
THE LATEST IN THE STEADY ADVANCE
BY THOSE SOWING DISTRUST IN
ELECTIONS BEING PUT ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT.
A SECRETARY OF STATE RUNNING TO
OVERSEE HIS STATE'S ELECTION.
>> I BELIEVE IT WAS STOLEN,
YEAH.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE WERE ENOUGH
IRREGULARITIES THAT WE NEED TO
DO AN AUDIT.
>> Reporter: AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER SECRETARY OF STATE
CANDIDATE WHO DOESN'T BELIEVE
THE 2020 RESULTS.
ELECTION LIARS ON STATE BALLOTS
SHOW TRUMP'S GRIP ON THE DEVELOP
CELEBRATED BY MIKE LINDELL AT
CPAC.
>> EVERYBODY IS GOING TO VOTE
THESE GREAT CANDIDATES LIKE KARI
LAKE AND OVERRIDE THE MACHINES.
>> Reporter: ON THE CPAC AGENDA.
>> THEY STOLE THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> Reporter: IT IS RELITIGATING
2020 AND ALSO LOOKING AHEAD TO
NOVEMBER AND BEYOND.
>> THEY WANT TO RIG ELECTIONS,
INSTITUTIONALIZE VOTER FRAUD,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW IT.
>> I SEE YOUR HAT THERE.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT FOR YOU TO
TALK ABOUT 2020 AS WE LOOK AT
2022.
>> HE WON.
HE WON IN 2020 HANDS DOWN ACROSS
THE NATION.
>> Reporter: WHAT DOES THIS SAY
ABOUT WHERE